[Music]
hey folks welcome to this special
livestream edition of the Dark Horse
podcast I am here with dr. Heather
huiying who was I kid you not
evergreens most popular professor and
for very good reason we are going to
talk today about what took place at
Evergreen both before and after the
protests that turned so quickly into
riots this is a an anniversary for us
it's the third anniversary of the day
that 50 students I had never met showed
up at my classroom accusing me of racism
and demanding that I either resign or be
fired I refused and things descended
from there into certainly chaos and I
would argue an argument which was in
fact the the plan of many of the
protesters all right where shall we
begin I think you wanted to start before
we talk a little bit about what
evergreen had been in its past and how
it was founded about the spectacular and
public nature of the collapse just start
there that's what you had said to me
yeah the problem for us is that we were
for reasons that will surely come up in
our discussion here we were fully
ensconced in a life in Olympia
Washington and our our teaching lives
were the core of it so we spent 14 years
in my case 15 years in yours
teaching in an environment that freed us
to do remarkable things when the
collapse happened and suddenly the
existence of evergreen was on many
people's minds who didn't know anything
about it beforehand and our roles there
was suddenly front and center it gave
people an impression of the place and
inevitably that impression would be
misleading it couldn't help it because
you know at best it was a vignette and
it was a vignette at a moment that
things
very abnormal but it has been kind of a
struggle since the thing occurred to try
to correct the record so that people you
know we don't want it to be recorded in
people's minds as a cartoon and we
wanted to be recorded as the actual
descent into madness that it was but
descent from what that's really the
tough part the public nature of the
descent overwrote the true nature of
what was actually going on there which
wasn't all good but nonetheless there
was nuance yes um particularly on the
political right would argue that this is
the inevitable end of any place that had
broken so many of the rules of the
status quo model of higher ed as
evergreen dead and we have and will
continue to push back quite firmly on
that there was this this didn't have to
happen
certainly evergreen ended up being game
of all and thus as anything that is
gamble will happen it got gamed but
there was nothing about the original
nature of the school in its attempt to
get rid of some of the top-down generic
sit and rose and ask question you speak
only when spoken to Zoar model of higher
ed that evergreen was resisting and had
broken that inherently led to this and
in fact you know it's some of the
evidence for that is that none of our
students and indeed none of the students
of the handful of other faculty there
who were doing you know and I'm sure
there were more than a handful but it
wasn't everyone by any means there were
a handful of other feather there whom we
were close with none of our students
under their students were part of this
madness they were there trying to engage
their brains their bodies their minds in
a pursuit of truth beauty compassion any
number of things but they were they were
not invested in or participating in the
madness yeah in fact the thing that
occurred to me this morning as I was
reflecting on the anniversary was that
at some level evergreen where it worked
was
it was a attempt to instantiate the sort
of Star Trek model of getting along
we're basically one puts aside the
superficial stuff and you team up for
some sort of a larger goal and you know
so the the aspect of the college that
worked really did manage to look past
people's superficial characteristics and
to very good effect okay so it seems
like we're kind of we're kind of going
someplace right I thought you wanted to
start with something spectacular talking
about what the madness looked like we're
gonna get there but as long as we're
doing this let's say we want this to be
amusing and cathartic and something that
actually gets us someplace someplace new
but let's just can I just go into what I
what I had thought about us doing second
since we're sort of easing into it
anyway so I'm just going to talk a
little bit to begin about what the
mission of the college was and and in
particular a nearly founding faculty who
died last month who was of particular
note and I think he really epitomized
what evergreen could be okay so everyone
was founded by visionaries and
innovators by people who in the late
1960s saw the status quo in higher ed as
too nimble I mean as too rigid and not
nimble enough by interactive enough for
the times or for the future that they
imagined was coming the founding faculty
were in eclectic bunch and you taught
with a few of them actually and we were
at Evergreen starting in 2002 and 2003
respectively for the tail end of the
tenure of the founding faculty just a
few of them remained at the point that
we showed up at that point you taught
with Tom Rainey and David Milne and I
think I think that was it in terms of
the founding faculty whom you talked
with and the the faculty who weren't
quite founding but got there really
early included Steve Herman who died
last month and Steve was a great man he
was a great educator and naturalist a
great mentor and a friend he was also an
ornithologist and Cod did he know birds
I don't I've never met anyone else who
knew birds as well as he did although
his students
caught up to him pretty you know where
it worked to catch up with him his
students adored him his colleagues did
not and I think that was that was
telling if I can if I can interject one
thing so students very frequently
bounced between your programs and my
programs and into the programs that we
taught together yeah in general the best
of our students during the summer would
go off and they would take summer
ornithology with Steve so although I
barely knew him he was like the third
member of the team in some ways because
what they learned from us on campus
during the year they then put into
practice in the field with birds and so
anyway he was a very important figure in
art in our community that's right and a
parent and apparently I didn't know this
but in looking back through some old
emails in the last few days I found that
he actually used to talk about running
his own separate College within
Evergreen as as we did as well right
so he also he not only did he know birds
he knew it was possible at Evergreen and
in the natural world and in the hearts
and minds of students and it's so much
else too so I was told that the position
that I was hired to in a in a common
tradition in academia was to replace
someone and that someone in my case was
Steve and it was clearly impossible to
actually replace him but I was I was his
academic so you replaced him in the
daytime curriculum he continued to teach
summer ornithology
that's right throughout the period that
we were there that's right so I was told
by many faculty at Evergreen during my
tenure there that Steve was quarrelsome
and a curmudgeon and cantankerous and
not worth engaging with and I was then
very grateful to become friends with him
quickly once I was even told by faculty
colleague when I was being a thorn in
this person's side that I was just like
Steve Herman and I smiled and gave
thanks for the unintended compliment
which further worked this guy as you I
think you were in the room when this
happened Steve Herman appreciated honest
and honorable feedback he craved it and
not many people gave it to him because
they found him scary
I thought that it had to be his way or
the highway but in fact it was quite the
opposite he he had no patience though
for complacency for sick of fancy for
cowardice or for laziness he had no
patience for these things and he gave
people the truth whether they wanted to
hear it or not and this is of course
part of a big part of why he had a
reputation for being cantankerous
because people didn't always like what
he had to say to them he was kind and
wonderful and honorable but he he did
not suffer fools lightly I was just
going to say he did not suffer
administrators lightly well and this is
though I did have a line here he was not
cantankerous despite what some of his
former colleagues have claimed what he
was was totally intolerant of [ __ ]
he had courage wit and humor depth of
reason and compassion and love for all
forms of life except perhaps for cowards
and soulless bureaucrats for which he
had no love and no patience so just two
more things about Steve before we use
this to embark on talking about what
what evergreen was more broadly one of
my favorite memories of Steve is from
sitting around a campfire as so many
deep and meaningful memories are
especially from Evergreen it was 2012
and he and I were at Inova patia a field
station in Sonora Mexico on the Sea of
Cortez Steve at first second students
had first taken students to this magical
place its land and water together birds
and mangroves and cactus ten years
earlier and in the interim his daughter
and son-in-law Sally and Adam had turned
it into a small rustic beautiful field
station every year every spring I guess
it was every winter quarter Steve got
some number of students something
between four and ten to do field work
down at Nava patia and this year I was
sponsoring the contracts of those
students and I was able to go down there
for ten days and I was visiting the
students whose work I was overseeing and
experiencing firsthand this place that I
had heard so much about both from Steve
and just some degree from Sally and Adam
who I didn't know well at that point but
also from the generations of students
before
Steve had driven down with a friend Anna
Steve was already old it was already
retired but he had driven down it you
know near the border of Sonora and
Sinaloa in Mexico and one night after a
full day of field work that we all
engaged in under a nearly full moon all
of us sat around a campfire on this thin
strip of shoreline on the Sea of Cortez
and passed around a bottle of
lechuguilla which is the local agave
liquor and played guitar Steve did as
well as a few of the students and told
stories and Steve's stories were always
full of humor and and bashing of those
who needed bashing and honor for those
who deserved honor tales of birds and
people mostly and just just stunning so
then in early 2017
whenever Grimm was blowing up Steve and
I had an interaction on line about the
vandalism that had taken place at the
Natural History Museum because one of
the things that happened during the
protests that turned into riots at
Evergreen was that some of the activists
went after not all of campus but
specifically the science buildings in
the library and a number of windows were
smashed at the Natural History Museum
and in the science labs and other
vandalism happened at the library and
also at the newly named les purse hall
named for the former president who was
an excellent president of the college so
he and I were going back and forth
talking about what to do and how it
wasn't actually even safe to go onto
campus to do the cleanup but that the
specimens and the collections were at
risk and he said with regard to the
anarchy on campus quote I too am in
disbelief I've made some minor efforts
to find colleagues to join me in
supporting bread silence is a usual
result but some expressed support but
want to keep it secret who would have
thought we had evergreen word Bob yeah
this is such an important part of the
story of what happened and actually it
points rather exactly to what I think
one of the major themes and lessons of
the entire thing
was for me and for us which is that
crisis reveals people's character for
both better and worse yeah and we saw
spectacular examples of both we didn't I
will say we saw much less of it much
less courage amongst the faculty than I
would have hoped and expected hoped and
expected people that we would have
counted as friends were absolutely
silent or worse or worse yeah some of
them were far worse and that's a very
troubling thing to discover amongst the
faculty the ones who did stand up some
very surprising people came to our aid
but almost all of them retired yeah they
were almost all emeritus which means
that the college had no grasp on them
anymore well it did but it also meant
that they came from an era in which the
college was really about something much
more substantive and anyway I know I got
told and I think you got told that we
were like founding faculty members in
the wrong generation frequently which
you know I take to have been a
compliment but anyway the thing is
current faculty did not show up a few of
them did a very very tiny number like
Paris in particular is the one whose
name most people will know if they know
any of them but there were a few others
there were a few and some of the
academic staff as well so I was gonna
say Amex staff staff were more likely to
stand up even though they were far less
safe than the tenured faculty yeah and
then the people who shined the brightest
were students so a hundred percent a
huge fraction of our students and I mean
really a majority of our students we
heard from and where were actively
trying to to fight this thing and we've
course heard from many other students
and you know many of you will be
familiar with Benjamin Boyce who we came
to know in the aftermath of this and he
has done stunning work documenting what
happened in the year or two leading up
to it and what happened afterwards and
you know that that points to the student
body that actually did exist at
Evergreen that Evergreen has gotten
mocked for instance for having an
accepted
policy that was like 99% often 98 99 %
and it always felt to us like this
actually was a positive thing that no
this was not a selective college it
wasn't a highly selective college or
even a fairly a selective College by
most measures but what it allowed and
you know sure there were people who came
to the door that were not capable of
actually doing any kind of work that was
useful and for the most part we didn't
see those because over in the sciences
students who really were not interested
in doing any work or or capable didn't
even show up but we had so many students
who had been failed by school and they
were many of them were told that they
had failed school but I will say no they
were failed by school and some of them
came in to our classrooms saying I know
I'm dumb because I've been told I'm dumb
all my life by teachers and not a single
student who ever came to me and said
that was dumb or incapable or lazy or
incoherent or or incapable of developing
you know deep critical thinking on
issues evolutionary and beyond so I want
to there are a lot of things wrapped up
in what you just said and I want to
highlight a few of them yeah one thing
is the lack of selectivity of the
college produced two populations inside
the college and the two populations have
everything to do with what unfolded yeah
so you had people who showed up there
because it was the College of last
resort they could get in they couldn't
get in somewhere else and many of them
largely through no fault of their own
through the failure of the schools that
they had come from didn't have the
skills to do the work and then there
were there was a large population of
misfits and oddballs and unusual people
people just who didn't have a taste for
the elite colleges and we saw them all
and because you know it's a strange
thing to say but because you and I were
both very very popular our classes
overflowed there were more we never
didn't have a waitlist never done with
this climbing of enrollment when
everyone else is having nearly everyone
else having a hard time filling classes
we had waitlist and what this meant
oddly we weren't in most cases except in
the rare case of study abroad in most
cases we were not allowed to decide who
came into our classes but there was if a
backdoor mechanism and we used it so
there was this tradition that before any
term began which the thing called
academic fair in which you could sit
down with any professor you wanted to
and talk to them about the program that
we're teaching and before registration
happened so yes this is a way for
students to hate the consumer metaphor
here but shop for the full-time program
that they would be taking for a quarter
or two quarters or three quarters and
this was a month or so before
registration or you know a day before
registration a month or more before
classes started so when students asked
us for advice we told them a lot of
stuff we would tell them whether the
program they were considering taking was
likely to be any good but the key thing
was it made all the difference in the
world who was teaching a good professor
who was teaching something you maybe
weren't that interested in would
probably give you something of high
value a terrible professor who was
teaching something that you were
nominally interested in was very
unlikely to teach you anything and
you're reliable to feel because these
were full-time programs you're reliable
to feel trapped so anyway the academic
fair was like an opportunity to
interview professors but I also took it
and you took it as a opportunity to
interview students and figure out
whether or not they were a good fit and
in my case in particular often they
weren't because I wasn't that normal
kind of professor and so you know you
might have to be ready for my deficits
and if you were prepared for them there
was a lot you could get out of it but
but in any case by discouraging students
who wouldn't be a good fit for the
program and encouraging those who would
be a good fit and in my case I always
let in a few extras people who showed
particular promise but didn't you know
didn't register in time or something
didn't make it into the class I would
left those in and this would adjust the
the character of the room the room would
be really high quality and my feeling
was as long as you had one person in the
room was willing to volley with you you
could teach the others to do it and you
could get a really great teaching
environment
up and running pretty quickly absolutely
so anyway that created an opportunity
for us to build a community of people
who were super high-caliber even in a
college that wasn't selective right we
weren't allowed to be formally selected
but informally it happened and this in
we also in students would often show it
from past programs and sit in on one or
more many weeks of classes simply
because they wanted to continue to be
part of the conversation that we're
having the ongoing evolutionary
conversation and so having these having
these basically alums of our programs in
the room very often also raised the
level of discussion in the room oh
absolutely they functioned like TAS and
they were there just because they were
hungry to find the community was still
having the conversation that they had
benefited from I late in the game found
out that there was a proper term for
this which I borrowed from Steve Jobs
Steve Jobs who famously dropped out of
was it read yeah I think I think a Steve
Jobs dropped out of college but he
didn't stop going and I kept going was
trying to save his parents their tuition
money but he wasn't interested in not
learning and so he went and just took
what he wanted so he called himself a
drop in write and these students who
came back to our programs became
drop-ins and in any case it created a
couple of things one it created a very
delightful teaching environment for us
which I think made us a little bit less
aware of just how bad things were
descending into madness
in the larger College because our
community was healthy the larger
communities descent into madness was I
mean we were aware of it but I don't
think we were as alarmed as we should
have been which meant that it until the
last year it would have caught us off
guard although I do remember
conversation certainly between us and a
few of our other colleagues who were
saying you know students remain amazing
what we can do with the curriculum and
with education with this model is
amazing but when I come on to campus I
just keep my head down and go from my
classroom to my office and home I don't
want it increasingly
we were fighting over the last several
years that are our supposed peers or
going off the rails
our supposin peers were going off the
rails going after each other and the
good ones were keeping their head down
mm-hm actually maybe as long as we're
here can we look at some of those
pictures from our sure you got these
stuff I don't know I don't know what
you've got us got in store so let me
just set this up a little bit so Heather
became excellent at creating study
abroad programs at a price that was
unheard of and the price really
shouldn't matter except that what it
meant was that a range of students could
go on the study abroad programs who
never would have been able to afford it
at a normal college doing this at a
normal rate the price was incredibly low
it was incredibly late and and I worked
with them to the students who were
eligible for Pell grants I worked with
them to get them some some funds
basically scholarships that over half of
my students who applied every time I did
study abroad got these such that they
actually went into debt very little for
the experience of a six eight eleven
week study abroad in Panama or Ecuador
right so these things were inexpensive
which meant they were more diverse than
they would otherwise be
they were intensive you got them helped
you worked with them to be able to go
and they were also just much better than
you would be able to source anywhere
else so the final one the one I went on
with you I didn't that we did together
yes we did together and you know I'm
plenty good at showing up and teaching
but I was not responsible for making
this happen that was I was all Heather
but it was it was a totally different
experience I mean all of my study
Abroad's were amazing and flawed and
inglorious but this last one that we did
together was the two of us our two
children 30 students 30 s'tel Evan weeks
when I could have been with all years so
we had learned so again Evergreen
classes are full-time or at least they
were full-time which meant you the
professor teaches one class students
take one class you're with each other
full-time it's your job as we've already
been in the field with them in the
Pacific Northwest for a couple of weeks
we'd really seen them and we'd
elected them from all of the applicants
to get to the 50 that we started with in
the fall and then we trimmed that number
farther to travel with 30 students to
Ecuador for 11 weeks in January through
April of 2016 and for those of you who
don't know Ecuador Ecuador is a small
country by some measures but it is
terrifically diverse not only does it
contain the most diverse habitat on
earth as far as we know in the Amazon
one of the places that we visited but it
also has you know the Altiplano high and
the Andes it's got cloud forests it's
got an amazing diversity of habitats and
creatures and cultures and so anyway
it's a spectacular place and to spend oh
and the Galapagos of course to spend
eleven weeks touring with students that
you know really well who are you know
because this was evergreen we were
biologists but we were teaching about
paleoanthropology we were teaching about
evolutionary ecology we were teaching
about evolutionary dynamics and cultural
history and and modern cultural norms
and expectations in Ecuador as well and
so we got to basically use Ecuador as
the test case for all of these things we
could go look at it so anyway this was
happening the year before
evergreen came apart now we want you to
see what evergreen looked like when it
was firing on all cylinders so let's
let's put up some some photos all right
well I'm going to set this image up and
then hopefully Zak will be able to put
it on the screen for you the image is a
picture of 30 students plus Zak with a
bus in kind of the distant background
and these students are experiencing
something utterly remarkable now what
has just happened is these students have
just encountered the headwaters of the
Amazon they have just crossed into the
watershed that becomes hundreds of miles
away the Amazon River and where they are
standing it is but a trickle behind them
you can see the first Cecropia trees
they've ever encountered these will
become
a very common feature of our discussions
because there's such an important
feature of tropical forests but in any
case they're up here in the clouds in
this cold location watching you know
essentially the process that creates the
Amazon at its very beginning and they're
excited you can see that these are
students that are happy to be having
this experience they didn't expect it
but they're excited by what they're able
to actually walk up to and touch it's
such an amazing picture it really takes
me back and we've heard from two of the
people in this picture in the last
couple of days with regard to this being
an anniversary that's coming up and
we've been in touch of course with
another we work with on a regular basis
so you know yeah three three three of
the people in this photo we've we've
been in touch with in the last week and
you know probably another ten of them
we're in regular contact with so in fact
for those of you who are watching and
not just listening the woman kneeling in
the front row is Odette who will come up
here in a couple of other photos she's a
good friend of ours we've seen her
recently
but anyway her story actually tells the
story of what happened at evergreens so
well that anyway I think we just can't
avoid exploring it so let's go a little
further here so this image is of Heather
and Zack and Toby although Zack is
barely recognizable in this photo and a
student of ours who we've run into this
is carnival this is the night before
carnival which is the the night of the
grandfather night of the grandfathers
and the tradition in in Ecuador
basically is for people to run around
like madmen spray each other with foam
and anyway our students have taken to
this and they're participating and we're
participating and this is a great
cultural lesson and you know I don't
know that the foam tradition is
wonderful or absurd or whatever it might
be but it's the reality of what takes
place in this beautiful colonial city in
Ecuador
you know here we are having run into a
student who's obviously fully integrated
himself into this tradition yeah let's
see that's maybe the hat factor yet all
right so here are our students it's a
day trip from cuenca a day trip out of
Kalinka these students are watching
women make panama hats in a
all-female hat collective that exists in
ecuador and so we saw the whole process
of how they made hats again Odette
here's front and center
let's see another day yeah okay from
Cahuenga so this is a very surprising
habitat that we are hiking through this
is carhops cajas natural National Park
you can see these Peaks which are almost
always in shrouded in clouds it's ultra
cold anyway in a really magical place
and I think we have a picture of let's
see another picture all right so here's
Odette discovering carhops National Park
now I hate to do this because in some
sense I don't want to sully cajas
national park or the wonderful reality
of Odette with the terrible thing that
happened to her in some sense it's
parallel to what happened to us you know
we were teaching in a way that was
extremely rewarding and then something
monstrous came for us but I think I
should read something that did not
intend for this to be public but I did
ask her if it was okay if I read part of
what she wrote I will try to adjust it
so that it makes sense so he's
discussing and when did she write this
she she sent it to me out of the blue
this morning oh this is today yeah she
she was realizing that it was the third
anniversary of May 23rd and that's
important to her for the same reason
it's important to us yeah so you know a
year after she was here in
National Park she is discussing the
meeting in which George bridges the
president of the college has ostensibly
agreed to address the concerns that the
students have advanced and she says that
some left the address with confidence
and assurance leaving the rest with even
more confusion in questions but as you
know there was no room for questions
these activists were acting as if they
were bored they wanted something to do
all in all students were upset that they
had failed at college and decided to get
the institution to pay for their
shortcomings
I was diligently on campus that week
this would be week nine and ten
she said the museum got vandalized okay
this is the same thing you were
referencing that Steve had discussed the
cows windows were broken and shattered
people were roaming around with bats
there were no police campus was covered
in graffiti normal students in quotes
would not make eye contact with me on
campus they were afraid of me they were
afraid of my skin color I was followed
and prevented from entering lab one the
lab one building surrounded by a group
of activists who were screaming all
sorts of nonsense but were in fact
shouting I shouldn't be studying science
their exact words were a piece of [ __ ]
for studying science crazy people's law
are people's lives so corrupt that they
are going to actually take time to
target and accost complete strangers do
you know how much effort that takes how
exhausting it is she says I was able to
leave the library which was barricaded
by the protesters who were really
writers at that point he says I was able
to leave the library solely based on the
way I looked in comparison to the
captors I was confronted at lab one for
the same reason the second resistance
was displayed proving myself not going
along with the crowd
I was either deemed a lost soul a
traitor or a white sympathizer you're
benefiting from white privilege my
captor said I'll never forget that by
their own logic so were they one thing I
will never understand is how people
cannot think for themselves no matter
where you fall you must be able to think
this is a college
there are supposed to be thousands of
thinkers present what happened to them
where did they go that's amazing
yes he Oded I know it's it's so dead and
so he had never heard though she and you
and I have talked a lot many many many
hours and the three years since
Evergreen blew up and I'd never the one
thing in there I hadn't heard before was
that other students who weren't part of
the protests avoided her were scared of
her because of her color because of her
skin color it's astounding it's the most
upsetting feature of this whole thing
because I mean I must tell you I learned
something about race from our debt as
I've mentioned elsewhere
I took a debt to be black but in talking
to her about and she was very open with
us you know her family is a rather must
as a Caribbean African rivers European
debt is of European descent and the fact
is as one can easily imagine once
somebody points you to it in her case
she doesn't feel black or not black
these are the two sides of her family
and you know that you know if one does
not default to mother or father or one
way of thinking or the other the point
is that's the nature of the way human
beings are she's just she's just an
extraordinary human being who's a
scientist and a ballerina and a writer
and an artist and brilliant at
phylogenetic trees and at fieldwork and
it's and and she was actually one of the
students who came to Evergreen entirely
of her own volition she could have
gotten in nearly anywhere she she was an
excellent student and not because she
was a follower she but because she was
just an excellent student who was
creative and hardworking and
analytically beyond competent she came
to Evergreen because she loved the model
and so you know she was not a misfit in
any way
arriving in our classroom and boy at
this point the point this picture was
taken she had been my student
consistently for almost two full years
and yours for only
one quarter less than that yeah I met
her and as with so many of the students
including almost all the ones who are in
that boat accident with me later in the
same trip there as they entered college
for the first time the Ashman in college
and so this this highlights one of the
things so Odette was simultaneously a
student of ours and a friend of ours and
these two things were not in conflict
she put her trust in us for good reason
I think and it paid off for her but this
did not mean that we couldn't also be
friends and so she shows up all kinds of
places those of us who've been following
us carefully will know of the terrible
boat accident that you were you were in
Odette was in the boat accident with you
was badly injured as you were the day
before that boat accident she and I had
walked down the face of this crater
together the class had been looking at
this volcanic crater and we had spent I
don't know a half an hour or an hour
involved in conversation I don't
remember what it was but I do remember
how fun it was walking down this crater
with her and remarking on the biology
that was there and talking about lives I
think she was talking to me she loves
live theater and she was talking to me
about some of her favorites but and also
she shows up on the day of absence I did
not have class it was a Wednesday and I
did not have class scheduled but I had
said in the letter that became famous I
had said you should expect to find me on
campus and I didn't want not to live up
to it so I went to campus and I ran into
Odette and we went and had a
conversation for an hour and I later
asked her if she had arranged to find me
to keep me out of trouble and she said
no it hadn't even occurred to her and in
fact we didn't even talk about they have
absence it wasn't it wasn't a worthwhile
type of conversation from our
perspective yeah so do you want to like
to take this down you want to show a few
more pictures before we move let's let's
move to a couple more
yeah let's look at this one all right
this is a picture of students involved
in a mud fight in the Napo River I love
this one I love this moment so the Napo
is a tributary of the Amazon and later
in the trip we will find ourselves in a
different part of the Amazon and another
tributary called the Shira Puna a
tributary of the Napo but anyway here
these guys are they're having a mud
fight they're having a mud fight in a
tributary of the Amazon in in the Amazon
basin in ecuador and you know what
they're learning yes this act this is
education this is the picture when I
wrote that New York Times op-ed on
nature being risky and that's why
students and everyone need it this is
the picture that I'd hoped could
accompany it but it turns out that if
you're writing about college students
that they have college students do the
art for the piece so it wasn't an option
but this this qualifies as some of the
highly educational work that these
students were doing and of course they
also did field work and they took data
and they did analysis and they reported
them out to us and often by candlelight
all swatting at mosquitoes in remote
places with you know no doors or screens
or running water but this - they're
having fun and learning okay what else
done all right here maybe that's oh I
guess let's see that's a picture that's
cos again yeah that's car house again I
guess if we go yeah there's one last
picture of carhops this is interesting
it's Lucas leading a group of people
Lucas who I also feel like they've
gotten in anywhere but oh yeah fishing
really appreciated the the unusual model
and then maybe the last thing that's a
self-portrait that I took of you and me
the night after the boat accident in
which you very nearly died and ice
45 minutes sure that you had so anyway I
don't know what that picture is doing
here but it means something important to
me so I figured I'd include it yeah okay
my wing go back to yeah photos now so
you go for it well the thing about you
know if we can just I hate to take
advantage of what Odette has supplied us
here but what happened to Odette being
confronted by other students accused of
basically being a race traitor for
studying science this so encapsulate the
confusion that was at the heart of the
Evergreen riots and meltdown that I just
think it makes sense to spend just a
moment thinking about what it implies
somebody without race on their mind at
all has decided that they even I mean
she didn't know that she was science
oriented until you know she encountered
you and that first program and saw that
there was just all of this amazing power
to understand that was potentially at
her disposal did brilliantly and then
here she is being confronted by violent
thugs who are trying to shame her into
abandoning what she's discovered that's
so wonderful rather than what should
have happened
which is the whole college should have
you know led people in the direction of
ideas that actually empower you rather
than turn you into into monsters and so
something about it just strikes me as
the confrontation between the civil
rights movements understanding of the
objective and this new intersectional
garbage that is it's it's most dangerous
foe so that's it that's a good segue I
think I wanted to share something from
one of the faculty the emeritus faculty
who stood up in defense of of you and us
and truth and reason beginning in
January of 2017
and it totally unexpected and neither of
us had any knowledge of him except that
we imagined that he might fall on the
other side of this but he very much did
not so just an excerpt from Alain Nasser
who in his sign-off reminds his sign off
to this email reminds his readers that
he is in fact not white he says I have
been following the remarkable truly
remarkable posts on the alleged epidemic
of racism rampant among evergreen
faculty this is in January of 2017 let's
be clear he writes that there are no
traces whatever of racism whatever Green
is highly unlikely given the
unmistakable force of racism in American
society but what is alleged by some very
privileged people of color I should add
must be thought by the complainants to
be a virtual epidemic given the sweeping
and sometimes vitriolic nature of the
complaints issued on this thread there
is in fact no such epidemic on this
campus later in the same email he says a
small number of faculty and staff here
have embarked upon a campaign and a
series of posts that would look
ludicrous and quasi pathological to most
decent readers outside of this campus
and the real white fragility here is to
be found among the white folks dripping
with guilt and liable to intimidation
yeah I asked did not imagine that Allen
was going to show up in our defense but
I must say it was so heartening and you
know it goes back to the theme that we
started with which is the crisis reveals
everyone's character exactly right and
you know for those of you who are
potentially facing such things in the
world this is an important thing you
should expect it to happen and you
should expect people to to disappoint
you
and you should expect people to show up
with strengths you didn't know they have
because both things happen what you
shouldn't do is assume that because
somebody is decent enough on a
day-to-day basis when there is no crisis
that they're not going to flee or turn
on you just because they're a nice
person the fact is cowardice is a very
dangerous drug yeah it sure is
now you had mentioned some of some of
the crazy happening behind the scenes
that too for the most part was not
revealed
the world I'd like to share just two
examples okay of this from the first
from February 15 2017 so when it was
good and clear that this was going off
the rails to us on the inside but the
rest of the world didn't know a student
by the name of Mike Penn Halligan I'm
probably mispronouncing his name writes
dear Brett to be clear this is to all
staff and faculty I think and so some
students were on this list because they
were stew they were student employees so
he writes dear Brett to be clear as a
scientist student you and your racist
colleagues so the reason I won't recruit
future students which indepent Lee
incidentally was his job to recruit
future students you and your racist
colleagues are the reason I won't
recruit future students if the current
reorganization that I support makes you
uncomfortable
I have no question to lean in on
supporting those plans thoughtfully Mike
Penn telling him I was thoughtful yeah
so thoughtful and then May 27th so four
days into the the riots Stephen flus T
who signs off as professor of fortune I
have no idea what that means
begins May 27th email this way thank you
and he names a bunch of people including
Zoltan and Naima who some viewers will
be familiar with and my apologies for
snipping your words to which I now had
far too many of my own
this is I'm just including this as an
example of the the kind of language that
critical theory produces in academics so
this this is an academic so so in the
grievant Studies in critical theory that
this he thinks this makes sense I am
merely an adjunct attempt with little
real status here and am thus in a
particularly vulnerable position as such
I have remained silent in public I have
remained while silent while supremacist
evolutionary just so stories as stephen
jay gould rightly called them with an
entirely appropriate car lot to the
flatulent poet laureate of white
supremacy Richard Kipling have been
promulgated I have remained silent while
privileged wind and moaned interminably
as it tried to usurp the status of a
beleaguered minority and I'm gonna just
skip some of this it's ridiculous and
now propagandizing steps of the most
thoughtfully self-absorbed sort have
been taken that invoke outside
Islands down upon a great many of my
students my partner and myself all of us
truly vulnerable persons at Evergreen
and in the larger region beyond on
numerous axis of identity plainly
visible and otherwise that's marvelous
it is so marvelous is Professor fortune
like soldier it's supposed to be yes I
does he know what that means
that's a mercenary professor I I mean
and that fits perfectly actually oh wait
there's one more from him later in the
same you say thanks Brett please be
aware that this like all similar
communications received previously and
any that may be coming in future are
also being forwarded under separate
cover to legal counsel yeah quits yet
that I'm not quite but yeah that's so I
was look this is what caused us to look
at each other over and over again and go
I can't believe that they keep on
doubling down that they keep on doing
these ridiculous things and isn't it a
shame that the world will never know as
it turns out that the world did come to
know and yet still they kind of won
oh that they clearly once saw they won
the college and it's failing but amazing
well look I would love for people to get
the full context of the marvelous thing
that was going on at the same place that
the terrible thing was going on and what
that implies it's really it's a deep
lesson and it's it's a difficult one I
have to say my favorite email of all I
can't find either so my favorite email
and I've it maybe flus T I'm not sure
but anyway the the idea was that it he
was describing a conflict I think during
the riots and he said the important
question here is not who's right here
but who's white and I thought hey what
does that mean and B it does I mean how
that's the important thing
I mean it just it just puts into such a
completely stark relief this this
dichotomy that Jonathan highness
many times right that you can maximize
truth that even if the seaching the
searching for truth or you can maximize
the quest for social justice but you can
not maximize both simultaneously and
that quote not who's right
but who's white here yeah just is the
perfect synopsis of the choice well it's
almost like that was the secret behind
the scenes thing that he wasn't supposed
to reveal was really the core organizing
principle of this thing oh my god that
right and wrong has been replaced by
white and not white and it's like and I
call it and you're gonna you know that
idea isn't good enough for the
brainstorming session when somebody then
shoots it down you've built a movement
around this oh god we've got I mean
there's lots and lots from from this one
but Naima Lowe posted to her Facebook
page just before the canoe meeting the
famous canoe meeting a proposed rule for
the upcoming meeting now it did not end
up getting adopted but she proposed this
rule for the upcoming faculty meeting
for the upcoming canoe meeting so lately
in fairness this was I'm pretty sure
tongue-in-cheek but I do think it I mean
why is the joke funny to her is the
question anyway what she says is only
appointed or approved whites can speak
and only when spoken to
yeah i I don't think that's a good I did
that surprise you
yeah no it doesn't I mean I could I
could go on but maybe this is yeah the
point is made lightly yeah that inside
the school it was a pressure cooker for
the last year right and there were many
there many students some on staff fewer
on faculty fewer on out but although
there were few brave people on admin who
were watching the thing and could not
figure out how to stop it admin had some
power should have but you were doing
more than anyone you were
you were trying everything possible and
it was unstoppable and they said so in
as many words in as many ways there
began to be a cabal of first a couple
and ultimately a good 10 or 14 faculty
members who every time you wrote any
email to the staff faculty thread the
old staff faculty thread they would
respond almost as a unit and just pile
on and accuse you of all the things
we've now become familiar with you have
been accused of with of course no
evidence because there can be no
evidence for something that isn't true
yeah and you know the the hard part to
understand is that this energy existed
on the campus and you know not unique to
Evergreen but it was catalyzed the
nucleating event was the hiring of
George bridges who you know there's a
debate amongst those of us who followed
the story closely about whether or not
he is a diabolical or
just inept and really the answer is well
he's clearly inept but that's not you
know you can be both and what he did was
he partnered with this madness in order
to advance his own agenda and you know
it unleashed this on the campus which I
don't think he expected but less Purse
the previous president had been holding
it at bay and frankly less purse because
he happened to be a black man could more
easily dismiss out of hand without
giving any time to these people at all
any such complaints that came his way I
presume he was doing it you know we
basically never saw it until he stepped
down and we got bridges well we did see
it and it's one of theirs is of idiot no
not not during his tour yes but famously
as one of the main buildings on the
campus was remodeled and then
named in his honor he came back from
retirement for the dedication and the
very same people who show up again and
again and again in the protests of of
you and me
they still activists a student activists
those same students confronted him and
this is the place where they reveal you
know he invokes Martin Luther King you
know he reasons with them and he says
look I'm not deaf to your concerns but
there's a right way and there's a right
objective and what you all are doing is
dangerous to this and you know they've
shut him down
and he invokes Martin Luther King and
one of the protesters says yes but dr.
King is dead as if that's an indictment
of what he advocated but anyway so yes
ultimately even less purse you know I
can't make headway against them on the
other hand you can't make headway
against them coming back to campus for
an afternoon having ceded power having
stepped down after a long tenure
eighteen months or so before so I don't
I don't think that though that group of
activists could have done that in the
middle of less versus young as president
no I can't I can't imagine that they
would have nor would he have done any of
the foolish things that George did that
empowered the the mob so that they had
such great leverage so where where do we
where do we point our fingers right
there are there are many types of
players and there are many individual
players and some of them are awful but
most of them aren't simply awful
right there's admin level George bridges
being the most famous there's faculty
and staff and their students and as it
happened because the video that went
viral that the students themselves took
and posted and then someone unknown to
us took that video off of someone's
Facebook page or something and put it on
YouTube it was easy to point a finger at
the students and say they're entitled
they're ridiculous they you know belong
and this is this is Maoist and they're
at the base of this neither you nor I
find them to be central in the story
actually
the activist students right I mean I
think one of them clearly is yeah but
this actually goes to a discussion I've
been having on a number of fronts with a
number of different people where I hear
people give advice and the advice is of
this nature you will be better if you
imagine that everyone is acting in good
faith and my feeling about this is when
people even if somebody is advocating
something terrible very often
they don't understand that that's what
they're doing and assuming that they are
acting in good faith relative to what
they internally believe actually works
it's helpful but if you just make this a
a universal approach you are signing up
to make yourself vulnerable to every
truly bad actor and these truly bad
actors exists not in large numbers in
small numbers but they do prey on those
who use a heuristic like that and make
themselves incapable of fending off an
attack and so I think one of the things
that I believe happened is that a place
like evergreen accumulates people who
are basically cowards I mean academia in
general seems to but evergreen may be
even worse and an assumption like that
is basically a neon sign advertising for
people who are really just in it for
themselves and you know I I saw
something I'm Benjamin Boyce put up a an
interview that he had done with a
student of mine who was a student at the
time the protests broke out actually is
that could you put up the video of
George talking and then put up the
alright we will see if this works it's
not working that's unfortunate
so in any case this is a student of mine
who says that she had worked as a
waitress at a restaurant near
near the college and that George would
come in frequently and she would end up
serving him and she describes that there
is a moment at which he realizes that he
has met her before and that she is an
evergreen student and she describes that
he puts on this smile and he asks her
how her studies are going and he
inquires about whether or not she is a
liking evergreen and her comment is I
just had the sense that he that that is
the moment at which he decided to care
to seem like he gave a damn this reminds
me of so mean of our former colleagues
the probably are going someplace else
with this but I was marveling reading
through some of the past emails at the
kind of thinking that we know everyone
now is sort of immersed in as I believe
all women right for them with the me2
movement but back in the year leading up
to the Evergreen protests we had a lot
of believe all students and believe all
people of color and it's the same
horrifying game Apple idea that any
demographic should be inherently
believable because any demographic is
inherently truth-seeking and lovely in
every regard is obviously simply going
to be false what do you tell music all
right folks here's what we're gonna do
we are gonna continue to forge ahead we
are hearing in the chat that people are
having trouble with the audio if it
becomes intolerable come back when we've
uploaded the video we're recording it
locally so we can do a fine version and
put it up quickly we apologize for this
it is downstream of us that much we know
all right
that's unfortunate so I was talking
about this this believe all students
logic that was showing up a lot in
conversations and emails in the
2016-2017 academic year and I will say
that I tended to see this from exactly
the people who will talk about and we
need to be student-centered and we need
to be student focused and almost always
when I knew anything about these faculty
and for in some cases I had talked with
some of them I know that as soon as the
doors were closed and there wasn't any
possibility that students were listening
and these are exactly the faculty who
were dehumanizing students refusing to
learn their names much less anything
about them and you know this is this is
one of the things that was absolutely
possible and necessary to use Evergreen
in the maximally best way possible which
was to take the opportunity of having a
full-time program for 10 weeks or 20
weeks or 30 weeks and not just learn
everyone's names for that a couple of
days obviously but learn something about
them so that you actually had an ongoing
sense of who they were as people they're
not brains in jars and you know I
developed this rubric late in the game
at Evergreen at the point that I had
grown quite tired of most of our
colleagues precisely because of this and
said cut there should be just a you know
I have a low bar for what it should take
to be a successful faculty at Evergreen
and it's two things
you should actually believe in the
fundamental humanity of your students
and you should have something real that
you know that you're capable of
communicating and so many faculty failed
one or both of those one of both of
those rubrics and this thing that you
say about your student who was waiting
tables at a place where George bridges
came in that she saw the mass go up yeah
which means the mass sometimes comes
down and this is certainly the sense
that we had of him throughout it was not
who he appeared that you know hapless so
total genius who knows but you know some
kind of combination of the two and
certainly the evil genius trope would
use hapless as a thing to hide behind
yeah the irony of course though is that
many of the people who
leading the charge would tell you that
the enemy was old white men and from the
outside it really looks to me like the
college they've now announced the
Georgia will retire at the end of his
contract they're going to give him the
right to teach at the college after he's
retired which is very unusual the
college is now selling a false story
that it's you know the the pandemic that
has caused the failure and they were
before that they were selling the false
story that the decline in enrollment was
going before bridges arrived and of
course it's not that there wasn't an
enrollment issue but it's quite obvious
from the graph that there's a
precipitous catastrophe surrounding
George and you know his plan for the
place and somehow as he's brought the
place to its knees and they can't bear
to have a conversation with him in which
they say actually George you've done a
rotten job you know don't let the
doorknob hit you on the way out no
they're still talking about him having
used wisdom throughout difficult times
it's depressing they're praising the man
and so they they've liquidated a college
and what did that college do that
college served underserved people who
did they liquidate it for so is not to
embarrass Georgia bridges what kind of
upside-down world are we living in right
now how did they not notice that they
were in some sense doing exactly the
thing that they declared the world was
guilty of that's right all right
it's an hour-ish it's an hour-ish you
know there's there's a ton more that we
can talk about of course we were
planning to take a break at some point
and take super check questions but only
those relating to evergreen in the
second hour and to choose choose as we
see fit you know we may see one or two
that we end up talking about for the
entire time or we may go through many of
them I'm I feel like there's so much
more to say oh let me just say this so
the thing about crisis were feeling
everyone's character yeah we've talked a
little bit about the expected places
where we found support mostly in
students and a little bit also about the
unexpected including from Alain Nasser
and let me just say one more of those
and then mention some previously unknown
to us that the public records officer at
the college I had I had work I had done
a Freedom of Information Act request
after there was an assault on campus by
protesters of a student which Stacy
Brown who we heard from today who was
the police chief at the time who was
amazing she had told me about this and
said you need to do a FOIA request and
then they were someone there was was
blocking access for a long time
and Wendy Morris got it to me and she
sent me a CD and included a handwritten
note notably
that could not be tracked via other FOIA
requests in which she said that she
really hoped that we were doing well and
that she was so sorry for what we were
going through and that we were all part
of a community this is from a staff
person who we had never met who actually
turns out as a woman of color a black
woman who took took time out and frankly
probably some risk to make a point of
reaching out and there were many there
ain't many emails like that from people
as well people we'd never heard from
before I never heard of before
but let me just say that of course as
you know the reason we can do this now
and have an audience is in part because
so many people that we had not
previously known but we're known to the
world reached out to us right away
Nicholas Christakis Jonathan Hite Jerry
Coyne Michael Shermer you went on dave
rubin and tucker carlson and sam Harris
and Joe Rogan and you know all Bo and
more and more and more and more right
now and all of those people and many
more than forgetting to list here and
wouldn't have time to I'll Bob Woodson
one of the one of the original civil
rights leaders who actually
wanted to come and get some of the
original civil rights leaders with him
and come to campus in March on campus
with us during the protests and we were
ready to say yes and then it descended
into into actual violence but it was
actually yes into senator that he was
still ready to go the problem was it was
week 10 and so there was no way to get
him here in time the students were
attending the last the last week of the
quarter so people were gonna scatter to
the winds yeah so let me just end with
one one more this is someone we we don't
know we never met who wrote to the all
staff faculty email and I'll just tell
just read the email he says dear mr.
bridges and evergreen faculty and staff
I am one of evergreens earlier graduates
I entered as a junior the day the
college's doors open and graduated in
1973 I had later got my doctorate in
zoology at UC Davis I remain in close
contact with dr. Steve Herman and many
of his students I am very proud to be a
gooey duck that's the mascot of
Evergreen especially as a part of the
tremendous tradition of field biology
that dr. Herman and other faculty of
maintained over the years a tradition
virtually unique in the nation thus it
is with a sense of shame that I
witnessed the treatment of Brett
Weinstein by a mob of close minded
students who seemed to mistake the
purpose of a liberal arts education you
sir must take a more forceful role in
support of dr. Weinstein I imagine I am
one of many thousands of gooey duck
alums waiting anxiously to see that dr.
Weinstein keeps his job
further I suspect that many other alums
like I question the wisdom of the
college's new equality of outcome agenda
described in dr. Weinstein's Wall Street
Journal commentary in closing please get
a grip people this is my college you're
messing with
sincerely David F Whitaker class of 1973
class of 73 so that's like it's like the
second year that it was up and running
yeah yeah and you know we you ended up
receiving thousands of emails and I went
through most of them and there were I
think two really heinous death threat
level anti-semitic things and a couple
of other mildly negative things and
otherwise it was from all demographics
all parts of the world ages sex races
everything educational level career
interests political spectrum to say
thank you and please keep fighting the
good fight yeah it was it was like a
thousand to one yeah it's amazing all
right shall we take a break and then
come back and answer some questions
let's do it
all right sorry for the technical
difficulties it's downstream of us I
wish we are trying to switch ISPs in an
effort to get away from this but anyway
for now it is what it is we will see you
in a few minutes the link to the next
stream will be in the description of
this one
like subscribe notify comment and we'll
see you shortly